okay legend of korra season 2 and see
how they did two episodes back-to-back
we're gonna do the two episodes
back-to-back um i was presented as one
day so well no this did jacket one
gender divide it in regards okay so the
beginning of the season two spirits and
uh you know i swear to god these guys
for the most part the creators really do
listen to the fans because like all the
stuff we were talking about in the free
seeds like now I wish they sort of fixed
this with you know these bags yeah like
they have for common either going
outside the fucking City
they're encountering these spirits that
are very colorful and allow service
different style of animation uh so so
far I'm really liking it I'm really
enjoying it new characters I love these
characters while the new character get a
lot of name complaints ya know I even
bothering ya know I'm just gonna be like
the brother and sister like the uncle
the father I'm just gonna do that um and
it seems like they're introducing a lot
more stuff and yeah it just seems like
everything sort of seems much more you
know pumped up and there's more
interesting story going up more sort of
intriguing story and I think we're the
first one the focus the big focus and
interesting to be the city like that was
sort of like the main Wow
look at this we're really gonna show
this off I get the feeling this one's
gonna be the spirits like that's gonna
be the big point where they're really
gonna show okay yes it's scary it's
gonna be like a experience okay to just
say a lot of really swish in there loop
okay just go I sound stupid that sounded
but nonetheless I like the fact that
that seems like that's going to be the
main focus for like the animation the
style and stuff because maybe just even
more color and a more sort of a fun
diverse visual style and we're really
getting it now and sorry these new these
kid that brother and sister that look
exactly like I mean they're hilarious oh
don't worry my little turtle duck I'll
protect you oh god hilarious oh wait
wait do you want me to be a slave or a
boyfriend yes wouldn't be trapeze I like
I can't remember so boo me before the
it was like so many of the lassies yeah
but like he's great when we get a little
bit of attention sister to UM and
they're wonderful you get sort of this
you get more chorus vada which I like I
like it me more of the parents in there
uh so so far I'm liking it there's only
the only real thing that still seems to
be a bit of a problem and I think you're
noticing it too is that we had the same
thought yeah I mean it we should say at
least a start I sell our yeah I actually
saw it first because I watched it i HD
DVR did so you were at a convention so I
actually saw it first so I was watching
it a second time with Doug today and he
was saying the exact same things I was
thinking when I saw it every to me I was
just like yeah thank you
and that's when uh Korra just looks at
tents and says maybe I need a new
teacher maybe and it sort of very
ruthlessly says you know I'm bored with
you you're not good enough and blah blah
I was gonna say it she was a bit yeah I
just could say that right I saw it I was
like what a bitch
yeah I turned to my wife and I was like
wow what a bitch yes yeah here's the
thing moving on to another teacher and
honestly the uncle who the minute you
see a river I was just like I'll be your
Tarlac for the season it's like it which
was the exact same thing I thought I did
I turned to my wife like after he
uttered all of like maybe ten lines of
dialogue so far and I was like villain
yeah I'm a quitter meet our lock style
villain is is he's going to be a
sympathetic style villain yeah villain
and it's kind of sad cuz we were looking
at you know a him start talking we were
saying like I want to like you but it's
so obvious you're gonna be the bad guy
so I can't side with you but I like what
you see I like that you know and the
stuff he started giving her giving her
the trust giving her the confidence I
think is serve a legit point where
nobody has been doing that at the same
time you know the character is supposed
to evolve and supposed to learn things
and at times you
she does but then you have regresses
though yeah licensee that was Anakin
painful they're absolutely wonderful
he's really a new teacher and I get and
the funny thing is because she did the
same thing to her father but I get that
and welcome honor was your time those
was lying to you this entire time a year
this from you um also is a fuckup
apparently according to you know the
whole max right like I get that I would
be legitimately upset and be like know
obviously the spirits don't like you you
need to leave but with Tenzin he was
being perfectly reasonable inevitably
die soon as if she wanted to be kind of
stirred and say okay you know this is
where we need to part ways that's fine
but he says it has been an honor serving
you I am you know it walks away and
she's just like yeah it was Nagano it's
not cool and I with you that if she said
no it's time to part ways and even she's
mistaken or not which honestly given
everything sir demonstrated I'm sort of
siding with her like no I think she
should sort of go on this journey like
everything even though it's probably
gonna be the wrong move I understand the
moves it's like the attitude I did not
like yeah it's like way to make me
sympathize with your position but also
at the same time be like wow I hate you
yeah no it was not cool Iike that one
scene just really rubbed me the wrong
you get a little bit of her sniffing
amok Oh a few times which again comes
right out I'm sorry I'm such a pain and
again it's like you know it's like a cab
and I thought maca was being perfectly
reasonable ya know even like sometimes
it's for comedy like he's like well I
thought you wanted me to support you now
you want me to tell you the truth that
like okay that was cute but a lot of
those scenes I'm just like he's
perfectly reasonable and you're just
like freaking biting his head off yeah
and there's scenes where it's like you
you understand what she's going through
like I really like that scene where the
uncle says you know no you need to go in
alone I trust you to stuff in and she
says wow it's so rare I hear that and
it's you can sympathize so that you can
understand but at the same time it's
almost a little too warranted why people
don't trust her because she is
she just does not listen and again if
she starts off that way and gets better
and better fine but she's like you said
she's really impressing would have it
would have worked had this happened in
the first season but at the beginning of
the second season I'm like just going
Wow so all of that spiritual journey you
had in the first season just seems to
been chucked out the window here cuz all
of a sudden she's back to the scene yeah
angsty sort of I'm gonna bite your head
off for no reason are we gonna and I get
I like I know what they're going for in
that they want her to be technically
like in terms of fighting and stuff like
that she's much more advanced like I
like how she can go she could go in and
out of the Avatar state like in a blink
where with egg it was much harder for
him to do I like how she uses it to
cheat winning you know little races and
then like that stuff's great and it's
playful and it's fun but yeah what why
ever be so needlessly me especially just
something we do words you have to
consider the idea that perhaps not
knowing whether they were going to get a
season two and three or whatever they
wrote themselves into a corner and
they're like oh we totally advanced her
really quickly not knowing where we were
going to go with this whether we had the
option and now just like I guess we'll
kind of go back to this point I don't
know because I like I liked what you
said about with her leaving tensed that
this could have been done very smartly
very patiently and very much was showing
honor to her teacher well she feels
upset after the fact talking tamaco did
I do the right thing and they hold hands
I'm like yeah her motion I'm like why
were you so cruel about it yeah no it
says that that really bought yeah um and
you're a teacher yeah that's like that's
Tenzin man it's like okay they won't be
mad at tense he's like the most likeable
character um so so that that only
bothered me but everything else in the
show I mean that was pretty solid I
thought they're like somehow your
comments on my Facebook and he's like
what was just plotless and I'm like
there was so much plot in here I do it's
like standing up but yeah there was
almost too much plot I'm just like wow
did they cram a lot of stuff into an
three-episode thought say it balanced
out with the humor and the other
characters it was fine but yeah I
thought there was plenty of plot and
really interested where it's going if I
am in besides yeah besides the way they
treated her character if I have one
small complainants I'm hoping I'm wrong
but it seems like this new villain is
Tarlac 2.0 like I just like yeah I just
feel like we just saw this already even
kind of looks like tarrlok oh yeah
you're the same hairstyle yeah so that's
what the Water Tribe they've just like
chuck it out slightly almost like man it
must be a screwed up place up the pole
oh but and - we're talking about the
father where we're saying like it he was
kind of rightfully chewed out a little
bit red at the very least we understand
what what she's doing and why she's
doing it yeah with the father's eyes I
love that backstory it's a good bag no
it's a grape ah I'll be it's to me I
think they're setting up a conspiracy or
something like yeah I don't know if her
uncle was in on it make me her uncle set
this whole thing up to give an excuse to
invade the South sort of web looks like
it oh you be like oh yeah that actually
would make sense like he sets up the
brother to go out and then the spirits
come out and so forth yeah or or he set
this one up knowing what happened after
his brother did it so he destroys the
forest in the South Pole and then it's
like oh you guys need my help I'll just
send in my battleship as far as show
that especially this season is doing so
well at taking something like a
directory think it's gonna go in it
either goes there but speeds it up or
doesn't go that direction it is
frustrating just to see like yo Cora
come on that's frustrating because it's
meticulously plotted there is not a
wasted second in this episode like I
miss like men they just was one thing
after another they gave us all the
characters they needed their anymore
their kids - I like whatever yeah she's
the kids yeah oh yeah my favorite scene
in this whole episode is when she's
staring at the statute yeah like what's
going on yeah and then I what's going on
but she shares like this moment there I
was like this is a great quiet almost
missing somebody they're saying uh why
did you run away well they put these up
in front of me and
I ran away and that I love it's like no
faster they got it they got it is the
anti-shah model yeah like the Tomo
anti-shah blombo yeah so it's that was a
very legit see and I like like what's
going on with the connection there too
oh I can't wait to sees cuz yeah that
was my complaint about the first season
which I liked it Rob I was like yeah I
could use more kids and more humor and
already we got both of them yeah and
Bolin is forming much more of a
character outside just this is my
favorite Bolin episode every yeah
outside of just Zonk alight out sir so
now Jimmy engine somebody displaces
thank you good laughs you know it's much
more balanced out and the last thing
I'll say is the the spirit world even
has sort of this interesting feel right
down to the animation being very
different which I like it's almost like
animation from the first avatar Syria
from The Last Airbender which i think is
kind of cool
ah every new character so far has been
really interesting yeah I'm like I wanna
I love the the Howard Hughes guy that oh
god yeah yeah nothing great he's
wonderful yes let's do Howard Hughes
dressed as Prince training delivered I
think it's got Howard Hughes I'm
forgetting his name but to the guy who
like Owens Virgin Atlantic yeah I've you
know that that the crazy nutty
millionaire who does all the eccentrics
but I think when they were talking about
the movie thing cuz at first yeah this
is very Howard Hughes yeah are they
going this he's dressed like Prince and
he's got like the thin mustache and when
they did the movie they come on oh it's
Howard Hughes transportation into movies
I'm like the time period I'm like I got
it yeah but I think the eccentric Miz is
sort of more the the Virgen guy um
because he's always happy though and
let's go let's go hey you know how
Hughes was just kind of yes and I'm
interested what they're gonna do with
this ami because I love her character
and I was like she got shafted in the
first season she loses ma Co her dad you
know is a crazy villain that like I I'm
just like I'm hoping they do something
with that character cuz I was like she's
an ass-kicker yeah so the possibilities
seemed there even the spirit world I
mean it's like even SAR has this it
seems like it has this different way of
thinking and moving the first time we
can wait
spirit I was like this is the ghost of
dizzy devil it's like a little purple
guy or the guy was good I thought no oh
they get like more interesting and as I
get used to the character increases
science yeah again - I mean again just
going back to the avatar it's I seen
these great designs again uh different
locations and so I just to see the
spirits acknowledged again because that
was a big end of the original ones well
and I get it like I said because with
the first seasons very much the
technology it's really boomed and now
this is like what about the spirits or
the mondo que Fang and it's like I like
that um but we are cinema bego crystal
mismo isn't we've got the general Iroh
he'd the boss we need more Tabasco Nemo
Dante tell Dante Basco don't have like
the execs the boss okay the how like the
ataxia reveals last time I came on the
ship it's like and people will still
freak out just as much as like bask in
the Bosco yeah back to the Bhaskar
Bhaskar nice I was hoping I'd see more
of him like in this season set yeah who
knows maybe maybe a bottle poison so
what yeah so I I really like how it's
starting off I like the possibilities I
say man could evolve Korra please you
know like like rich ever learn yeah he
should that's the thing she gets please
don't be a tough face she can rush a
system was what the spiritual side and I
thought the way she dealt with her
father seemed to make sense and she said
and I thought it was a legitimate I
revenge she's like you should go fight
the spirits yeah but I am the bridge
between general than the this now she
has to live up to my potential like okay
that's gross she legitimately wants to
do this and help people out and yeah we
should treat it tense yeah I didn't get
over there and even is you know it's
gonna be a mistake you know the father's
gonna come back and redeem it so I mean
they're they're setting that up well you
know she's gonna probably go to Tenzin
at some point and you were right to the
you know my uncle's evil where the fuck
yeah when the father was called for the
Tenzin thing that did not seem it did
not need to be that harsh um so yeah
just have a character learn anybody you
still be here she still be a tough
answer Russian
stuff and still be like kind of
impatient but just make her make her
work you know some stuff that's the only
thing that's bothering me but I'm I'm
excited for this season it's just a good
set III want see where it's gonna go
I it's just that's the only thing that
that kind of bugs me is that I thought
all of these characters were it even
okay maka with the David grid with the
Caruso moment they're just like you know
good thing the police are here yeah I
think even has like the lines and stuff
like that I thought that was cute yeah I
think so overall I think he bamako has
improved a bit
I thought he actually was the weakest
thing in the last season um but that's
my only disappointment I'm like when I
have to look at this girl all of these
characters are great well Cara's okay
yeah but it's called The Legend of Korra
you think you'd get that pin down
perfect zone but hello well we'll see
where it goes so uh yeah good stuff and
we'll just keep them coming after I
reopen so hopefully sooner than uh we
did here because I guess that house
their convention but thread a night
Friday night next one there this time
watch it yes yes hopefully I'll get them
out as quickly as possible we'll see you
guys to the next one
take care